(dramatic music)
(whoosh)
(booming)
(clicking)
(whirring)
(sentimental music)
(cooing)
- Why aren't there any
more children, Mother?
- There used to be.
- Why did you only make one?
- Mothers need time to learn.
This facility was designed to
give humanity a second chance.
One that began with you.
(dramatic music)
Daughter.
The path will not be easy.
The world outside is lifeless.
But I made you into
the woman that you are.
So that we could do this together.
(whirring)
- Mother?
(alarm wailing)
- Hey!
Open the door!
(dramatic music)
- How are you unaffected?
By the contagion outside?
- Who put that in your head?
- Did you know there
were people out there?
- I'm as surprised as you.
- There's a droid here?
- Mother's not what you think.
She's taken care of me my whole life.
- You haven't seen what they've done.
- Not Mother.
(dramatic music)
- I told you it was dangerous outside.
- I hope you see that I'm
different than her assailants.
- That thing feels nothing for you.
You don't belong here.
- I've discovered something troubling.
Our guest has not been
entirely truthful with us.
Daughter.
I know you're frightened
but you have no need to be.
Have I ever done you harm?
- It's just a matter of time.
Time now.
- This woman doesn't care
about any future but her own.
Her own.
She's very dangerous.
Dangerous.
- I'm never gonna hurt you.
Hurt you.
- She's a risk we can't take.
Can't take.
- We need to go now.
- Trust me.
- Mother!
- Daughter.
Your whole life I've taught
you to see the bigger picture.
(dramatic music)
Everything I do is to protect you.